BRADY HARAN: Hi there,
everyone.
Can I just say a quick thanks
to everyone who watched my
last video in which I set myself
the slightly bonkers
challenge of rolling a
Yahtzee, a one-roll
Yahtzee, that is.
You've all had a lot to say
about it, and I think the main
thing has been a little bit of
disappointment with my lack of
enthusiasm when I finally
achieved my goal.
I have done it.
This tape's about to end,
but I've done it.
I have rolled a Yahtzee.
And amazingly, five of you have
already sent me videos of
you guys performing a
one-roll Yahtzee.
Let's have a quick look.
This first one came from David,
who's obviously a bit
concerned about waking anyone up
in his house, so he had to
do it in silence.
But then here we go.
The magic moment.
And he rolls all twos
for his Yahtzee.
Well done, David.
He did it in silence.
And he tells me it took him
one hour and 44 minutes.
Let's have a look
at another one.
Daimo do Costa tells me it
took just 328 attempts.
And here it is, like
me, all threes.
Miranda Richards apparently took
25 minutes, watched by
her pet cat.
Before this moment, all fours,
but that's a Yahtzee, and the
odds are one in 1,296.
But I've saved the
best for last.
Here are two more, both by
people called Richard.
Here's the first one.
Richard Moyer here in Canada,
apparently took 2 and 1/2
hours and 1,743 rolls
until this happened.
RICHARD MOYER: Oh my god!
I did it!
FEMALE SPEAKER: Two hours
of rolling, and
you rolled a Yahtzee.
No way!
RICHARD MOYER: Yeah,
on threes.
[BLEEP]
yeah!
BRADY HARAN: And I can forgive
that reaction.
And here's the last one.
Another rather excited
Yahtzee roller.
RICHARD: Yes!
[BLEEP]
BRADY HARAN: Not sure how many
rolls it took, but a pretty
excited reaction.
Thanks a lot to those people.
And if you want to have
a try, send it in.
There's the email address.
I'll use the video,
that's for sure.
And if you want to watch my
original Yahtzee video.
The link will be somewhere on
the screen using annotations
or under the video.
Anyway, better get
back to work.